Henry Winkler it's so funny Henry
Winkler is great in this and he plays
the acting teacher you've imprint you've
done you do an impression of Henry
Winkler where you use your hands a lot I
kind of do this yeah well you know Henry
would talk about people versus OJ
Simpson yeah and you go John Travolta in
that he always uses his hands his hands
are just so it's like they're only made
to handle teacups like a little tea and
you do when you do like Al Pacino hands
room huh yeah but you know how did you
remember heat heat DeNiro yeah it's
great where him and tone look where he's
yelling and like you could tell Tomac
and that scene is like what is happening
right now well he goes oh you did shot
walking your doggy thank you good to us
like I do what what are you meeting
right now but yeah he used his hands a
lot you know he's a guy that chief and I
like goes all over the place yeah with
his hands and gets really emotional with
it just in his hands you know yeah yeah
on the phone yeah just anywhere he can
use who's the guy who does his hands
really well for America is it watch his
hands all day right yeah it's just a lot
of like but the killer knew yes at his
time was I don't even look at him
anymore yeah just look at his hands yeah
yeah then they would have sex but there
was a you know
the DNA evidence was faulty yeah
you